There are so many factors at play when it
comes to making a movie that actually completing
one can feel like a miracle.
After months of blood, sweat, and tears, there’s
a lot riding on the final product.
As you’re about to see, it doesn’t always
end well.
Here are 10 Popular Movies That Actors and
Directors Regret.
Josh Trank, Fantastic Four
Given the insane success the MCU is currently
enjoying, it’s easy to assume that all their
movies are slam dunks.
But there’s one group of characters that
have been getting the short end of the cinematic
stick for quite some time now: the Fantastic
Four.
They’ve had a few shots at glory and fallen
spectacularly short every time.
The 2015 incarnation directed by Josh Trank
was no exception.
Hopes were high that a shakeup would be just
what the doctor ordered, but again the offering
fell flat.
Many blame the studio for muddying the waters
during post-production.
The movie was a let-down for everyone involved,
and talks of a sequel have been swept under
the rug for the time being.
Daniel Craig, Spectre
Daniel Craig made the PR team work for their
paychecks during press for 2015’s Spectre.
The actor is done with playing James Bond,
and he doesn’t care who knows it.
Craig has voiced concern over how 007 is part
of the problem with Hollywood depictions of
masculinity.
The actor argues that the super spy is a violent
misogynist and all-around prick.
And that might be true.
But after consistently being told what an
“honor” it is to play the character, fans
may have been surprised to hear the opposite.
Ryan Reynolds, X-Men Origins: Wolverine
Ryan Reynolds knew he’d be the perfect guy
to play Deadpool, so when the opportunity
came up back in 2009, the actor took it.
But anyone who’s seen X-Men Origins: Wolverine
knows the merc with a mouth started as the
merc without a mouth.
Reynolds was given every assurance that the
role was gonna be awesome, but it wasn’t
until he showed up on set that he realized
he’d been straight lied to.
The actor campaigned hard to have the character
taken in the right direction, and as a thanks
for his efforts, production threatened to
replace him.
After the success of the 2016 installment,
it’s hard to imagine the character as anything
less than great, but all good things take
time.
George Clooney - Batman & Robin
Of all the sins committed in the name of Batman,
there is one that reigns supreme, and will
never be forgiven for as long as the character
exists: bat nipples.
And while the batsuit modification first appears
in Batman Forever, it’s 1997’s Batman
& Robin that whipped audiences into a tizzy.
It’s not the only change that had fans pissed
off, but it’s definitely the funniest.
And just in case you think George Clooney
is oblivious to all this criticism, he’s
not.
It seems like he hates it more than any of
us could, even referring to it as “a waste
of money”.
Channing Tatum, G.I.
Joe Franchise
Contracts are a tricky thing, and can come
back to bite you in the butt if you don’t
read the fine print.
When Channing Tatum was a Hollywood newbie,
he signed a document that production used
to corral him into a role he never wanted:
Duke in the G.I.
Joe franchise.
The actor is on record as saying he hates
the movies.
And that if the bosses didn't threaten to
sue him to high heaven, he’d have passed
on the role completely.
The promise of guaranteed work seemed like
a gift at the time.
But the lack of agency over which work he
got to do was a major blow.
Woody Allen, Annie Hall
Creative types are notoriously hard on themselves,
and Woody Allen is no exception.
The accomplished filmmaker has made some of
the most renowned classics in movie history.
And while many may find his films inaccessible
or pretentious, for others, nothing can compare.
But for Allen, once the movie is made, the
party’s over.
And the director has talked about distancing
himself from the final product because it’s
almost always a disappointment.
Even one of his most popular works, Annie
Hall.
Allen says he was dissatisfied with the final
cut because audiences only focused on the
relationship between he and Diane Keaton.
What he considers a small portion of the film’s
larger, more cerebral message.
Edward Norton, The Incredible Hulk
Edward Norton was the star of 2008’s The
Incredible Hulk.
But you’d never know that by looking at
the press junket that followed.
The actor was so disappointed in the film
and it’s script that he refused to participate
in promotional interviews.
After joining the project, the actor reportedly
disagreed with the direction of the story
and constantly argued for changes to be made.
From his perspective, Norton explains that
he simply wasn’t afraid to speak his mind
about the poor decisions being made on set.
It seems as though everyone had high hopes
for the movie, but Norton came away the most
disappointed.
Bill Murray, Garfield
There are a handful of people in Hollywood
who have similar names.
And when those people get mixed up, some super
weird movies get made.
So when a script by Joel Cohen landed in front
of Bill Murray, he jumped at the opportunity
to work with the great mind behind The Big
Lebowski, No Country For Old Men, and Burn
After Reading.
Murray admits being apprehensive about wether
or not a lasagna-loving feline named Garfield
could carry an entire movie.
And when he learned that the story wasn’t
actually written by the Coen brothers like
he thought, it was too late.
Turns out, he agreed to work with the Joel
Cohen behind Daddy Day Camp, and Cheaper by
the Dozen.
Murray reportedly scrambled to make the script
funnier once he realized he was locked in,
but was met with constant resistance.
Halle Berry, Catwoman
Catwoman is a beloved character in the Batman
canon.
And any actress tapped to play the feisty
feline has some big claws to fill.
When the character was blessed with a solo
movie in 2004, hopes were high.
After a string of appearances in other bat-related
properties, finally the cat-burglar was going
to be the center of attention.
The movie was panned by audiences for being
over-the-top and cheesy, and is remembered
today for all the wrong reasons.
But when the movie won a boatload of Razzie’s
for being the “worst” across multiple
categories, star Halle Berry and screenplay
writer Michael Ferris showed off their senses
of humor, accepting their awards in person.
David Ayer, Suicide Squad
If you ever find yourself cursing Hollywood
for pumping out the same flick year after
year, consider what happens to filmmakers
who take risks.
2016’s Suicide Squad was another divisive
addition to the DCEU.
And David Ayer hasn’t heard the end of it
since.
The director has come under fire from all
sides of the debate, and oftentimes for things
outside of his control.
Ayer’s acknowledged some flaws in the final
cut, and said that if he could do things differently,
he would.
Ticket holders felt duped by a bait-and-switch
marketing strategy which led everyone to believe
the Joker would be a central figure in the
storyline.
And after reflecting on it, the director wishes
he’d given more screen time to the Clown
Prince of Crime.
Hey thanks for watching.
In a conversation about cinematic regrets,
those are the actors and directors who come
to mind for us.
But did we miss any of your favorites?
Join the conversation in the comments section,
and check out our channel for more videos.